do you have any concern over the fact
that this is it for emmy rossum on
shameless we lost Ian at the end I guess
the end of this first half of this
season in October from the show and now
Fiona's leaving and Emmy Rossum and you
were kind of the two linchpins I guess
of the show you guys were the each side
of the moral compass for a lot of it um
does that concern you that she's leaving
yeah it was really sad it was very
upsetting when she said she was going to
leave it's a little frightening but yet
on wells is really good
he says there's lots of stories yet to
be told and I wish her well I totally
understand why she's leaving and she's
got a big career I mean she's gonna do
great things she's a wonderful actor
mm-hmm but I'll still miss her yeah do
you get panicked about leaving stuff
like I would be panicked to leave
anything until it's absolutely run dry
because the idea yeah well you're smart
you're smart it doesn't come around too
often in this business where that you're
actually getting paid so I'm gonna ride
this horse all the way to the barn yeah
you probably should could you see guys I
mean there's a few stories classical
people that left projects before they
should have left them no yet right what
are you doing yeah yeah stupid
I mean you wonder I mean you go back to
the office and Steve Carrell leaving the
office before that that that well had
been tap dry and your la he made it he
made a good decision
did we leave one year before though like
I think it was like two or I think they
went on two or three - yeah enemies good
it was good he was really scible and it
was but I loved the last season in that
moment right that's a very difficult
decision I'm sure for him to make it big
I I know it was tough for me2 but she's
newly married and she wants to live in
New York and she had sold a pilot and
she's got a lot of fish to fry
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM app